hey guys how's it going so today we are
gonna be making donuts no I googled a
ton of doughnut recipes and some of them
were really difficult and I said no I
want this to be successful so what I did
was also find some doughnut pans on
Amazon do shop way too much on Amazon
found a super simple fluffy cake donut
recipe let's gather our ingredients I
actually pre measured these ingredients
today so you know I'm not messing around
2 cups of flour 3/4 cups of white sugar
2 teaspoons of baking powder shoot this
is baking soda oh gosh
baking powder 1/4 teaspoon of nutmeg 1/4
teaspoon of cinnamon 1 teaspoon of salt
3/4 cup of milk 1 teaspoon vanilla
extract these are the things that we're
not gonna make you 2 eggs 1 tablespoon
of shortening now we've got all of our
ingredients ready I'm gonna put this in
the blender because it's been a while
since I've used the blender and I know a
lot of you guys really just saying hello
why are you cooking with things that
you're supposed to cook with I ask
myself that every single time you also
want to pre-heat your oven to I believe
350 let's see oh 325 whatever let's
let's knock it down a couple 325 I keep
it losing the top of this one up there
where did you go I just used it well
then we're gonna have to figure out a
way to plug this hole up cuz I'm
blending this whether this calls for it
or not large bowl mix flour sugar 2
teaspoons of baking powder looks like a
teaspoon to me Oh God
that's way more than a teaspoon table
how much teaspoons are super small we're
gonna scoop out a little bit of that oh
forget it
nutmeg 1/4 teaspoon 1/4 ground cinnamon
salt
3/4 cup milk 2 eggs tsp vanilla extract
way more than teaspoon shortening it
looks like a tablespoon all right this
is gonna be potentially disastrous this
is what I set out to do and this is what
I'm gonna do gonna accomplish my goal no
matter what I have to do know who's
hiding now we're gonna have a successful
one I think I should probably add some
more sugar to this cuz I'm not sure oh
it's actually not bad I think this might
be good I hope you like do you like
cinnamon
do you really how many other moons are
there I think we're in luck
so those important things is you want to
spray your pan I don't know if you saw
the video that I did for my sister's
birthday we try to make a birthday cake
and something she didn't do was spray
the pan enough you gotta spring it good
good if it says no stick I spray it
anyway you will not be stuck put our
guys in here oh yeah this is already
just really well
[Music]
I don't know if that was the best way to
do it but at least I wash my hands so
make eight to ten minutes in the
preheated oven until doughnuts spring
back when touched let's bring back
alright let's put these in set a timer
for 12 minutes
no no just kidding cancel Alexa 9
minutes
mm-hmm that's my girl so for the glaze
we need 1 cup of confectioner's sugar 2
tablespoons of hot water 1/2 teaspoon
balm and extract I don't have almond
extract some use vanilla do I have
moment I don't think I do I don't
they're ready these babies are ready
what are those those are supposed to be
donuts so while those cool I'm gonna get
this started
I'll use my r2d2 measuring utilities 2
tablespoons of hot water
it's where's our tablespoons yeah that
was supposed to be a half teaspoon by
the way of almond extract and I used a
whole one so I hope you guys like almond
it's like the directions are right in
front of my face like it could not be
any closer they are right here I printed
them out so I wouldn't mess up and I
still messed up ok there we go I'm
excited about this I think it's gonna be
a nice little treat
very nice treat so these little guys are
pretty hot still look at that it's
perfect it's a perfect little dome on it
oh I'm so excited
it just popped right out of there
there's so much grease on that pan I'm
not really sure which side looks better
but we're just gonna dip it in the glaze
and then we're gonna have some sprinkles
and I think that everything's gonna be
awesome I mean that looks great I mean
this honestly could not have turned out
any more perfect now it's time for a
taste test because really this is all
that matters
are you ready it's actually not bad we
definitely put too much cinnamon in
whole thing is considered a pretty good
base and they look cute awesome thank
you guys so much for watching be sure to
leave me some comments and what you'd
like for me to try to make next and I
will hopefully try to make some of your
suggestions because actually pretty sure
you guys have been telling you to make
donuts for the longest time ever so here
it is it finally happened granted their
cake donuts and they're not fried or
anything crazy oh you guys the next
video by no matter how many times I walk
on this Third Street Promenade I just
can't get over the fact that this looks
exactly like real-life
Grand Theft Auto I don't think there was
any you farmers market in GTA GTA again
oh crap I love that game
is this some